first bit of advice that I have is
you're not going to sell it the truth is
your first script probably nobody should
ever see I've never personally seen it
and I think that that's a fantastic
dream scenario the percentages are so
small of people that that happens to
there are extremely talented writers out
there that probably deserve that to
happen a lot of new screenwriters think
that it's going to be easy and it's not
and they think that they're going to
write one script and it's going to sell
and that's not the way it works it's
like you're going to basically be you
have to love writing because you're
going to be doing a lot of it you're
going to be working on this story for
weeks or months to get a draft and then
you're going to be told unless you are
William Shakespeare you're going to be
told that there's a lot of problems and
you're going to have to do another draft
I was teaching class yesterday and I
told the writers if you're pitching a
script that is your first script don't
ever say this is my first script every
writer needs to have a couple of scripts
that they can show as this is an example
of what i can do I know my craft I know
the business of this art form I can
marshal people's emotions I can take a
character on a journey it's funny I at
my class class which meets tonight in
the first class I always brag about all
of the scripts it got written in the
classic became movies now most of the
people who succeed don't sell the
scripts that they write in the class
much less have the main into movies they
use them as showcases they win
representation they win development
deals and rewrite assignments and other
kinds of of rewards and even then once
you've sold a script people ask me
things like so how did you break in and
my answer is which time because it's
like every time you sell a script you do
the rewrites on that script and then
you're unemployed which means you have
to find another job I believe that those
stories really stem from writers who
actually have a career in motion and
they have contacts they can reach out to
and it's not that they sit and actually
write a screenplay over 48 hours it's
that they have an idea and I already
have a team of people who trust them
because they've delivered so many
quality scripts in the past and it was
the fact that I had done that and
delivered to them what they needed and
something that showed I actually cared
about the material and that I had some
intelligence and I had
style it was that that made them come to
me and say we want you to write a movie
called shark storm and for me to be in a
position to say no why would I want to
write a movie called shark storm haven't
we had enough dumb shark movies and they
went away and said I will find somebody
else to do it and then a month later
they came back to me and they said what
we really want you to do is write a
movie called sharknado people ask how do
you sell a screenplay and the first part
of that is is be brilliant in a writer
brilliant screenplay get your craft to
the point where it's so good people
can't can't deny it a good script
honestly kind of sells itself and that's
the biggest problem is that people don't
have the script that sells itself a
script will open doors for you you don't
have to open the door and that ends up
being the biggest problem people think
there's some trick to it but there's not
a trick to it the trick to it is to have
the script that when people read it they
say I want to spend money to make this
movie and I had to slog through this
thing to figure out what they were
trying to say and I gave up after a
couple of pages because they just did
abused me basically they'd stolen my
time they'd wasted my time on something
that wasn't a professional product that
could never be produced in its current
state generally speaking we find that
people have more success trying to work
with producers independent producers and
teaming up with people in that way as
opposed to trying to get an agent or
manager right out right out of the gate
almost all the writers I work with that
are super successful are people who can
be told they suck repeatedly and simply
go you're not right and I'm going to
work again one person liked it the other
person was like I like this character
and I like this character and one person
just eviscerated it and I cushman you
know like five days obsessing over that
one piece of coverage going you know the
son of a doesn't get it he's got
no sense of humor he's an idiot you know
what would he know and you know I went
through that hole
thing I gave it to this person because
he's a struggling writer and he said to
me man I just don't know you know what
to do I pitch it and they don't get me
and whatever and so I gave it to him and
I showed him seven versions is what it
took to get to this point so he left I
think but uh I just gave it to him I
said man it takes you awhile you can't
quit in the entertainment field you
there's a lot of rejection and and the
only way out of it is to take a deep
breath and realize that the person
you're talking to is just another human
being another thing is to make
relationships it is amazing how many
people that you meet one year pay off
five years later what I try to rely on
is people that actually want to help me
so if they read a script of mine and
it's the worst thing they've ever read
then it's not a fit for them to try and
help me and take it to anyone they
should
are easy so the more or less the ways
you don't have to live here you live
anywhere that's this mysterious thing to
producers and directors and actors and
they don't know where that comes from
and they need writers who can do that
and so you've got to be able to show I'm
one of those people who can do that
there's an all's well that ends well
story for you